io so che mi seguite da tanto magari
alcuni di voi mi seguono da anni ormai
io sono arrivato a un punto in cui un
sacco di iscritti no quindi devo portare
dei contenuti veramente di qualità
perché visti i miei scritti non posso
assolutamente essere da meno
[Musica]
però con che musica non lo stai dicendo
tomato way
c'è un fungo coi baffi sembra mio zio ma
io cerco la competizione
voglio le sport con l'acicatena non ho
tradotto il titolo perché penso non
abbia bisogno di traduzione tomato vuoi
vuol dire la via del pomodoro una
lettera per le signore hai una lumaca
quell'asta musica proprio necessaria di
sottofondo c'è naturalmente per forza
pomodoro che fuma la pipa e a una
lettera perché c'è un pomodoro che ha
una forchetta e mamma caracca sotto il
two mode 6 cromato 6 lisciato vivo o
morto
[Musica]
ha detto no io allora chi è bello è bene
che mi fai passare il tutorial così in
fretta così che io riesca ad avere il
tempo di leggerlo lato ubriaco è una
taverna dato è minuscola cioè non
c'entra non c'entra ma anche una persona
però entriamo al ratto briaco la
minuscola va beh nel buio si sente puzza
di urina ha infatti per conquistare un
po lo sparring staff angelo signore o
salve mentre si aspetta prende un
bicchierino offerto dalla casa grazie mi
sono fatto uno shock di osio vasco non
le dispiace accende al jukebox certo c'è
io sono un pomodoro e mi sono appena
fatto uno shot di vodka prego ma c'è
gente qua serve posso andare nel bagno a
qualcosa cercando di entrare domato le
cinematiche del questo gioco
sorrido v lo sceriffo doppio misto
sceriffo ma cosa posso dire signori ora
sta bruciando all'inferno ma che mai
si chiama time out
[Musica]
[Applauso]
su cristo che jobs che c'è ti pare che
in un gioco dove comando un pomodoro mi
sono preso un job seeker no dovrà
iniziare il peccato è competitivo sto
gioco ma se apriva accesso a può saperlo
c'è solo sa il vento brut dovrei degna a
mimì 20 le cose la dinamica iori soldi
che possono spendere per comprare le
cose mica non è stato fantastico
quando mi dicono che devo portare
contenuti di qualità
[Musica]
esatto scusi so che sta vomitando lo
voglio vedere chi è
voglio vederlo vi prego no non andro via
di qua senza vedere chiederti secolo
vabbè lasciamolo perdere
casini prima e lo sceriffo preme andare
di qua direttamente con incastrato sul
corpo di sto tizio porca vacca
faccio perché si sta roba aiuto
non so cosa succede quando succede
bellissima possa andare di qua a salve
ma io posso cambiare armi salve
se tu lo sceriffo se starò persone di
drogati e siringhe che kakà arca lacca
posso uscire il boss della carota ecco
l'ho ucciso e vabbè lo devo andare entro
qui è tutto un po poetico questo gioco è
andiamo avanti ragazzi permesso sono il
tomato cerco lo sceriffo cagano possa
esserci jump e reader o allora c'è anche
il fucile non avevo visto e ditelo
subito no
picchia che grafica incredibile come
posso liberarti sei veramente un figo
non so come liberarti sib senti non mi
può aiutare vado a meri me la cavo da
solo cosa sta succedendo lì salve
cetriolo 46 brutto
ho fatto uno spuntino cross che serve un
attimo ti prendo gli occhiali
che bel rischio piani questo
picchia collusi
lusi contro la forchetta perfetto che va
da sé che so ora un fucile mitragliatore
meno male non dovuta neanche ucciderlo
io io volevo liberare di un compagno ma
non so che c'è un topo gigante è
schietta altro che cazzo
ho fatto con le serie m rimane solo la
forchetta forchettate in bocca ai a tema
le ore che imbattibile è morto è morto
no è morto è morto ma si muove è morto
ma si muove è morto ma si muove è un
miracolo arcavacata che questo potrebbe
essere un problema sali salis ali salim
e le centrali veloce sai che non c'è
se satana aiuto che cosa trash che sta
bene un gioco veramente idilliaco e ci
auto convince del fatto che i soldi
siano ben spesi perché sono sono soldi
ben spesi questi io non lo so guarda
uscire a qualsiasi mostruoso armadio mio
caro amico sono finita aiutami
urgentemente non ho capito quello che mi
hai detto ma usciamo di qua vi prego
piuttosto casinò e siamo qua di nuovo
giorgio vanni mi mancava la lirica in
questo mancava solo quello e realtà tra
humour bridge gli atri film con matt al
quale mio padre o hai già tornato alla
passeggiata a luglio ma non devo
deciderlo chiu wai tattoo vuoi addio
babbo addio tomate toscano gli ha detto
va bene è stata che è stato molto
sentito come discorso che bello cielo in
hd
ma posso pensare chi stia pilotando
quell'elicottero zio ma non voglio
sapere
[Musica]
cavani è mi scusa mi stai correndo
addosso non posso fare diversamente
ci siamo arrivati ragazzi polizia questo
casino per il 3 state calmi turisti
mandando raga all ascensore
io non sto veramente capendo tutto
questo tutto dovrebbe andare a finire
scusami ma esco di qua ci stanno gli
elicotteri permesso o salve non sò se se
n'è accorto ma due siringhe sulla testa
ok allora a posto allora ha fatto bene
arcavata sono sceso ma che i ragazzi
siamo arrivati in città il clacson
ma sono arrivato a piedi non è vero
minchia fantastico hollywood
basta basta così io ne ho io
personalmente credo di meritarmi di
questi scritti cioè nel senso di non
faccio i giochi
io lì io di testo per voi c'è solo il
fatto di testare dei giochi così di me
ad honorem e io dovrei avresti scritto
proprio per il fatto che io mi impegno
per trovare su schifo spero che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi come mi piace anche
vari social comunicato descrizione
iscrivetevi sensata cristicchi e noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video dai ragazzi
[Musica]